pixels great storytelling requires great
characters not just in the words those
characters say but their actions and
appearance today character animation is
a cornerstone for visual effects and
animation and live-action features
whether it's Davy Jones Rango or the
Hulk creating photorealistic characters
that come alive requires the best in
technology the ilm shape sculpting
system is one of the most innovative
tools in character modeling and
animation before when an artist created
a character a series of all conceivable
poses had to be built because unknown
story elements would be added during the
course of a film's production this was
time-consuming and expensive not to
mention limiting with this system
artists can have sculptural control over
the character as it moves allowing them
to see their characters come to life in
all stages of design a tool set of
brushes allows high-res detail work
right into the surface geometry
providing quick enhancements while
maintaining the integrity of the
character animation and as for making
modifications at the eleventh hour this
system is invaluable because of how fast
the artist can see results want to make
the Hulk's muscles bigger a few brush
strokes and you've got bigger bulges
going you know you want to say for the
architecture and development of the ilm
shaped sculpting tool set the Academy
presents a technical achievement award
to Kerry Phillips Nicolas PAPRICA Phil
Peterson and Colette Mullen off
well this is a dream of an honor we want
to thank the Academy and the
investigating committee for this
recognition Phil Nico and Colette and I
would also like to acknowledge David
Bullock and Zoran and catcheth Salish
who wrote a major portion of this system
you should be up here with us we want to
thank everybody in the R&D group at ILM
for all the great things we've done
together over the years we owe an
enormous debt of gratitude to Michael
copper woz Paul G cocoa and James Tooley
who did such a convincing job of showing
this system to the investigating
committee we owe this to you thanks to
all the modelers and creature tdys at
ILM who made such amazing images with
the system over the years the the
process of working with you is has been
its own reward
and finally we like to thank our our
families my family Denise and Zoey
Alexander and my parents who were here
from North Carolina obviously I wouldn't
be here without you
in addition I would also like to thank
my lovely wife Isabelle with me here
tonight and our sons Jude and Oscar yes
I know a whole new generation of us
girls
Thank You Massie I'd like to thank my
mom and dad I wish you were here and my
beautiful wife Samantha who is here and
I've learned the trick to getting her to
come to an award show with me I have to
actually get one
and finally for Margo and Seth you can
sculpt voxels
thank you
Wow thank you for that Wow oh my gosh
now I'm gonna have trouble speaking okay
I wanted to thank Kerry Phillips for his
inspiring leadership of the Sheep
sculpting system over the years I'd also
want to thank my wonderful husband
Patrick and parents Pam and Don for
their endless support and encouragement
thank you